[Music]
firstly we agreed on the main features
of the budgetary instruments the Euro
Summit and the group will add a
strategic role on defining the precise
priorities that should be financed the
instrument will finance structural
reforms in public investments in
coherent proposals from member states
reflecting our common guidance and other
necessary conditions on banking union
there is broad convergence on the
principles that should guide the further
strengthening of the banking Union
countries are not yet ready to take a
decision on the next steps we have
solved all the issues that were decided
by the summit last year the ESM volt
provides a backstop to the single
resolution fund you will also find in
the treaty the enhanced role of the ESM
in crisis management if necessary
preparing new financial adjustment
programs together with the Commission of
course I presented yesterday to the Euro
group the main points of the
Commission's Spring European package and
in particular our assessment concerning
Italy everybody must understand that an
EDP year at this stage is warranted but
that we are looking together at the ways
to avoid that even if one must be sure
that the rules are there to be fully
respected they have to be credible and
we want them so